There are a lot of factors that make
Florida weird.
It is not like any other state that I
know of in the sense that there is no
Florida.
I mean,
there is Miami where I live,
which is Latin America.
Um,
there,
I mean,
it is.
you spend anytime in way Emma,
you will discover that not only is it
Latin America,
but it's more and more Latin America
every day.
Uh,
if you go south into the keys,
it's the sixties.
If you go west to Naples,
it's Ohio.
Uh,
if you go north to boca,
it's long island.
If you go to Orlando,
it's like a,
you know,
Russian limousine drivers driving,
tourists from everywhere in the world
all around.
And if you go much north of that,
it becomes Georgia and Alabama.
So it is really not.
One state has no coherence at all.
Um,
and I think less so as the time goes by.
It's a vacation spot.
So you have people coming down there
just to have fun.
A few people who are not feeling it
necessarily in a serious mood.
You have,
it's a very transient state.
So you have a lot of people,
again,
who don't,
don't feel rooted there but are just
there because it's convenient or the
weather's nice or whatever.
Uh,
and it's,
it's,
it's an,
it's a pretty corrupt state.
Governments,
we've had a lot of corruption in Florida
and um,
and it's convenient to uh,
you know,
all kinds of borders.
So it's very easy to get there from the
Caribbean,
from Latin America,
whatever.
So if you wanted to smuggle something in
Florida is a great place to start.
So the result of this is it's just kind
of this very loose during non
structured,
very nontraditional state where anything
feels like it could happen.
It's kind of like if you made Las Vegas
much bigger and with less controls,
you know,
not,
not the efficiency of the casinos and
the Las Vegas police department,
just as kind of a big area where people
feel they can do things.
And so people come from everywhere to,
to party to do whatever to do,
commit to commit criminal acts.
And it's the weather's warm.
So you can always be outside and you
know,
there's always a party going on
somewhere.
It's just conducive to weird things
happening.
My argument has been for a long time
that we are not,
it's not so much floridians who are
weird and I consider myself when I've
been there 30 years.
Uh,
it's,
it's people come to Florida.
We are like the Ellis Island for weird,
stupid people.
They come to come to Florida to commit
stupid acts.
If,
if,
um,
one example I like to use,
you know,
they've got an international,
a publicity woman was arrested driving
south on the overseas highway from Miami
to key to key west a,
b,
she had an accident,
um,
because she was shaving her bikini
region while a while driving.
Well,
she actually had an outsourced the
steering to her,
her passenger.
She was in a hurry to see her boyfriend
in key west.
This is all according to the police
report.
Um,
so she said he'd rather than pull over
to the side of the road to shave her
bikini region,
she keep going and outsource the,
uh,
steering to a passenger who was,
as it happened.
And this is where it's a Florida story,
her ex husband.
So they're,
they're driving south 40 miles an hour,
she's shaving,
but not looking at the road,
just operating,
accelerate your steering into what could
possibly go wrong.
Uh,
anyway,
the car in front of them slows down,
they slam into it is an accident,
international news or they don't get as
all Florida stories are,
you know,
oh,
can you believe it?
This woman,
is she shaving her bikini area while
driving to,
you know,
the woman was from Indiana.
That's the key.
So he was shaving her hoosier.
Um,
so,
which is I think with that term,
but we,
Florida gets the blame for that,
but it's actually,
you know,
it's,
it's somebody who came to Florida and
that's so often the case.
If somebody decides he wants to pleasure
himself into a stuffed animal in
Walmart,
that person's going to come wherever he
is.
He's going to go to Florida to commit
that act.
And you know,
this is why we have so many people doing
just so many weird things naked with
love reptiles.
We have a lot of reptiles also.
So.